My name is Jenny Korn.
I am a fellow, brand new, at the Berkman Klein
Center for Internet & Society.
I'll be looking at the way people talk about
race and gender, both online and in person.
I've pretty much always been interested in
issues of race because I'm a woman of color
that grew up in Alabama.
And I was reminded of my race in both positive
and negative ways at a very early age and
ever since then.
Talking about race more openly I think promotes,
my hope is that it promotes a more just society
eventually.
Because if we can't talk about race then we
definitely can't talk about racism.
And so we have to get to the point where talking
about race is not uncomfortable or feels forced.
But rather feels the same as saying what your
gender is or what your sexual orientation
is.
To say it all together naturally and comfortably
so that all of us can discuss what that means
to everybody across different levels of society.
The Internet has definitely changed the way
that we socialize but also the ways that we
interact with what we believe race is.
We're not only consumers of the Internet.
We're also producers.
We actually can create different ways to discuss
race.
We can share different representations of
And to me that's really exciting because we
are able to reduce the distance and the time
and the speed to creating those representations
online instead of relying on publishers for
books, or producers and distributors for movies.
We can overlook that and use the Internet
as the way to produce and broadcast and share
those representations.
And that means we can change old stereotypes
and make new representations of what we believe
it is to be of color, or to be white.
It's a brand new medium in terms of how far
we can get this kind of message.
I'm excited by the possibilities.